what was the lowest point of your career
probably [ __ ] on the pitch hi I'm
John
and these are my shocking questions hi
I'm Gary and these are my shocking
answers what was the last thing you
googled on your phone it was a
restaurant where I shouldn't go and to
get the to get the address it's not
talking about the phone Alan Shearer in
write or yourself it was the better
striker Oh me
that's his pick are you second out of
that oh oh god no excuse excuse me what
is your sexiest feature yeah it's a
favor Kate was your sexiest feature is
is which current Premier League player
is the most overrated
this is a good one if you had to punch a
famous person who would you punch Piers
Morgan yeah yeah which club did you most
enjoy playing for the one I was at at
the time I know it sounds like a bit of
a fudge but Lester was the team I always
wanted to play again oh it's my dreams
my clamps so that was special and
there's Everton was the best team I
played for in terms of the players that
they had yes I passed I was like a dream
and Thomas were great we won the FA Cup
and play with the gathering and their
stuff like that so I'd probably go
grandpa sake yeah what is the funniest
thing you've seen happen on the pitch I
always thought guys are pulling out in a
circle its dreadlocks aurelion Italia 90
every 10 minutes with music what is your
favorite flavor of Walkers crisps
soul-winning it so we're gonna go people
not fan you're not fun let's shop for
cheese onion all right let's talk okay
what was the lowest point of your career
probably [ __ ] on the pitch who is
the person you're most proud to have as
a follower in social media it's a good
question maybe prat someone like Raheem
Sterling who turned out to be you know
this really great spokesman for yes but
for all things in in football and the
bizarre one is probably destroyed
Mayweather yeah I don't really know why
I'm definitely what was the closest you
ever came to a yellow card that was
playing for Barcelona it's about his
second third season I was there so I was
getting towards my late 2000 tubes
there's the time when it was kind of
getting pointed out that I'm not had a
yellow card
I wish hadn't really thought about this
record see it gets such an unbelievably
bad decision against me I just started
running all right
and and he came up like that yes and
he's gone that list and forget yellow so
I said it I say it Spanish but I said I
see you're gonna book me for smiling for
laughing and he went and he put it back
in have you peed in the shower in the
last year no no and I talk I go before I
prefer not to speak who was the worst
player you've played with our dears
worst player play with a [ __ ] you guys
and like I don't think of a few friends
I think your thing
we've got to the last question now who
was the worst pundit you've had on much
of the day
oh dear Oh God look at this what is that
what's he Rex
[Music]